people can say what this sounds
judgmental well yeah you're damn right
I'm judging you especially when you're
telling me what to think and how to vote
are you judging me yes this was Martin
Sheen and a bunch of celebrities
whenever there's the white Apple like
background and Tim Cook doesn't appear
you know you're in for some political
crap from celebrities so the bunch of
celebrities lined up begging electors to
go against the will of the people of
course film with the Electoral College
because now therefore it's another for
now they're for it and I love how they
invoke the Federalist Papers in a resume
well what about federalism what really
what happened with not allowing [ __ ]
to take a dump in the middle of the
floor in North Carolina to do that but
they have the right to go completely
against the will of the people they
technically do have the right right look
there's the technical law I understand
there's the spirit of the law
they don't have respect Nora just a
rudimentary understanding of either
let's just start running through this
and we'll play and pause Jared let's go
Republican members of the electoral
college
this message is for you as you know our
founding fathers built the electoral
college to safeguard the American people
from the dangers of a demagogue and to
ensure that the presidency only go today
demagogues from the dangers of the
majority endowed with heretical rishabh
qualifications an eminent degree use of
Liberty we don't know someone who is
highly qualified for the job the
electric college was created
specifically the good James Cromwell it
wasn't to stop a demagogue right the
electoral college was to protect we've
talked about this the minority from the
mob rule of the majority that's why it
exists it exists so that someone doesn't
simply have to campaign New York San
Francisco Detroit Chicago boom done wrap
it up promised them free crap that's why
it exists not because somebody said mean
things on Twitter
no but I'm sure they're going to
encourage people to think for themselves
and to make their own decisions here and
they want people to engage in a rational
just very clever I'm not asking you to
vote for Hillary Clinton as you know the
Constitution gives electors the right to
vote for any eligible person any
eligible person no matter which party
they belong to but it should certainly
be someone you consider especially
competent especially commenting Jesus
set laws that's the muffle Rumer lady
there
[Music]
I don't oh yeah you know what people did
people didn't vote someone who they
thought was competent they saw a
murderer and Hillary Clinton and a guy
who's probably not super smart probably
not the best pic but certainly a lot
better than Hillary Clinton and Donald
Trump and they voted as president of the
United States of America by voting your
conscience you and other brave
Republican electors can give the House
of Representatives the option to select
a qualified candidate for the presidency
I stand with you I said with you they
stand with you if you do exactly what it
is that they want you to do and what
they want you to do is go back on your
vote or go back on the candidate your
constituency voted for and then say that
I stand with you so they can act like oh
gee golly we're part of the people first
off I bet you most dumbasses in that
video didn't even vote yes I lied it was
a sin I've committed many sins and you
just destroy your career when you do
this because you ruined there's one
thing to have a political opinion it's
another thing to actually insult the
intelligence of your audience hey listen
you guys voted or they're talking to a
they're talking to the electorate at
this point okay
well listen we know that you have this
role to fill we know that people voted
for this guy but we want you to vote for
the person we want you to vote for or
it's not the person you we want to vote
for just anyone but the person who
actually voted for so we can kick this
tin can on down the trail and then we
can call the next guy racist cuz you can
bet your ass if they chose John Kasich
who the left loves to act as though
they're buddies with now because he's
moderate if the House representatives
said hey okay John Kasich you'd hear
damn it we got to go through this again
here q another white tape celebrity
video that's what's going to happen
they're not your friends they're never
going to be your friends a piece and
crocodile's is futile and stupid and
that's actually a disservice to
crocodiles because at least they have
tough skin these are butter soft [ __ ]
this is an industry of people who don't
get out of bed until 10:00 a.m. this is
an industry of people with the highest
depression rate suicide rate and
ironically enough the only place in the
world where the divorce rate is actually
over 50% it's virtually 100% in the
entertainment industry and if you look
is it would this sounds judgmental yeah
you're damn right I'm judging you
especially when you're telling me what
to think and how to vote are you judging
me yes I'm judging you I'm not calling
you racist I'm not calling you
xenophobic I'm not calling you
transphobic I'm watching your video I'm
listening to your arguments and I'm
calling you a dumb bag of fecal matter
want you to subscribe I'm just look at
you why would I want you in my
subscribership I don't want you in a
suit you're bringing down the app you're
destroying the bell curve
put some pants on first maybe some
makeup go get a mani play I don't care
just don't subscribe